hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk
all about fasting mimicking diets known
as
fmds we'll talk about what they are what
they involve
how they are working their potential
benefits in terms of reducing the risk
factors for a variety of different
diseases
and why there seems to be benefits to
doing this fasting methods
for example in terms of being able to
conserve energy and instead promote
rejuvenation processes within cells
and then lastly we'll look at some open
questions regarding fmds
and where you can find additional
information so first then what are
fasting mimicking diets
well as kind of suggested by their name
they are a form of periodic fasting
coined by dr falter longo that's unlike
a water only fast includes a plant-based
caloric restricted diet containing low
proteins
low sugar and high unsaturated fats that
effectively mimic the same effect of
doing a water only periodic fast
and so water only fasting and caloric
restriction
has been shown in a variety of different
muscle organisms in particular yeast
to be able to extend lifespan and
protect against different age-associated
diseases
however there are some downsides with
doing such a severe periodic fast that
is water only
for example it could cause side effects
such as malnourishment
rapid weight loss reduced blood pressure
and hypoglycemia
as well as exacerbating existing
micronutrient deficiencies
plus there's the fact that going without
food is quite challenging
and as volder explains in his book the
longevity diet
patients who were undergoing
chemotherapy for the first time found it
difficult to undergo such an extreme
fast
and so this led walter to make the
decision to come up with an alternative
strategy
that could have the same effects and
benefits of fasting
but still enable the consumption of
foods and so this led to the fasting
mimicking diet
now you might be thinking this sounds a
little bit too good to be true
you get the benefits of fasting which
we'll go into later
and you still get to eat foods however
it's not just any old food that you can
eat
the fasting mimicking diet has been
devised such that it can promote the
effects of fasting
while standardizing dietary composition
providing nourishment
and minimizing the burden and side
effects associated with water only
fasting
and so if we take a closer look at what
actually the composition of the
fascinating diet
is you can see that the composition
should involve around nine to ten
percent protein
fifty to sixty percent fat that coming
mainly from unsaturated fats
and thirty to forty percent
carbohydrates
on top of that the diet is typically
carried out for a five-day period
with an additional reduction in calories
such that 1100 calories are consumed on
day one
with 800 calories being consumed on days
two to five
you can see an example of one of the
diets here as i've taken from falter's
book
so the fasting mimicking diet uses the
understanding
and use of food combinations to exploit
our bodies
and nade's ability to regenerate itself
at the cellular on organ level
and for these reasons that fmd can also
be referred to as a nutrient technology
now that sounds pretty cool so how was
this
fmd actually working well due to the
reduction in calories
and the reduction in protein in terms of
its dietary composition
during the fmd initially the glycogen in
your liver will get broken down into
glucose
and used as fuel by the body once the
glycogen store is used up
other molecules are used such as
pyruvate glycerol and
amino acids when these stools are
depleted the body then undergoes a
so-called metabolic switch
where instead it uses fatty acids as a
source of energy
the breakdown of fatty acids results in
the production of ketone bodies
and so higher levels of ketone bodies
and low levels of glucose are changes
that can be detected in the blood to
show that the protected state of fasting
has been entered
now what do i mean by this fake
protective state
well it all comes down to the
intercellular molecular signaling
pathways that are affected by fasting
as you can see in this figure here
reduction of glucose that happens during
this fast
in addition to the reduction of amino
acids due to this being a low protein
diet
reduces signaling through the mammalian
target of rapamycin
known as mtor this pathway usually
promotes cellular growth and protein
production within a cell
so during fasting in addition to there
also being a reduction in the levels of
igf-1
as we'll see later in some of the
patient data this instead enables the
activation of sirtuins
that activates cell stress responses
within a cell by activating the
transcription factor foxo and these
cell stress responses include the up
regulation of the process
autophagy a fundamental cellular process
for degrading
and recycling cellular components and
which the discovery of
was awarded the nobel prize in 2016
ribosomal biogenesis
and cellular protection genes including
antioxidant enzymes
and so the working hypothesis is that by
having this metabolic switch
it enables the replacement of damaged
components within a cell
in addition to the killing of damaged
cells and more on from that
it is thought that that is why the fmd
diet needs to occur for five days to
enable these changes to occur
but as important as the induction of
fasting is also the re-feeding process
and so this leads us on to the next
question of why does the fasting
mimicking diet work
well it's thought that it can awaken
rejuvenation from within
now again that sounds a little bit fake
so let's go into some more detail so
when talking about rejuvenation the
first thing that should come to mind are
stem cells
stem cells are cells that can divide
continuously
but also differentiate into different
cells and you can find stem cells in
different tissues within your body as
they are there to help regenerate
tissues and replace cells when they get
lost
and there's data from various male
studies whereby the mice have
undergone cycles of this fasting
mimicking diet
that has shown that this fmd can affect
tissue regeneration in multiple
different organs
for example it was shown that the fmd
can drive cell renewal of hermatopiatic
stem cells
in the immune system it could increase
mesenchymal stem cells in the bone
marrow
increase neurogenesis and brain tissue
promotes expression of cells associated
with muscle satellite stem cells
and lead to the regeneration of insulin
producing beta cells within the pancreas
and so these different benefits in these
different tissues led to the idea that
fmd could be protective in human
patients for a variety of different
diseases
including alzheimer's disease cancer
cardiovascular disease and diabetes
clinical trials are currently in
progress to understand how
fmd could be used in these different
diseases but it's too early to conclude
for certain at the moment that fmds
would be effective
but if we use diabetes as an example
based on the mouse data that's currently
been published
this seems very promising as the idea
behind fmd is that it's acting as a
rejuvenation process
whereby you end up with true reversal
and reactivation of these
potentially dormant stem cells as
opposed to just
blocking cholesterol synthesis or
lowering glucose levels with statins or
diabetes drugs
which may not be actually fixing the
original problem
so do we actually have any evidence for
this well next we'll take a look at some
of the human data whereby
patients of undergone fmd one of the
best papers to start with
is this 2017 publication for fasting
mimicking diets and risk factors for
aging diabetes cancer and cardiovascular
disease
which is the paper that summarizes a
randomized human clinical study
involving 100 patients whereby 71 of the
patients completed three
fmd cycles aging from 20 to 70 years old
and what they did was they then
evaluated the effects of the fasting
mimicking diet
on risk factors and markers for aging
cancer metabolic syndrome
and cardiovascular disease and it's also
worth pointing out that here they were
doing the fmd
once every month so they did it for
three months in total
and as you can see in this figure here
five to seven days after the completion
of their third cycle
there was an observed reduction in body
weight total body fat
blood pressure and igf-1 in comparison
to the normal diet
and you remember that i mentioned igf-1
earlier in terms of activating growth
pathways within a cell
so seeing a decrease in the levels by
following fmd
supports the fact that rejuvenation and
cell stress response pathways are
instead being activated
you'll notice though that there weren't
significant differences in terms of
reducing low density lipoprotein and
also reduction of
crp the c-reactive protein that is a
marker of inflammatory diseases
however when they stratified the
different patients
on the basis of them being either normal
risk or at high risk
for different age-related diseases you
instead can see
that there is a significant decline in
ldl levels
and crp and those more at risk of
developing these different diseases
and so this suggests that the fmd may
have more pronounced effects
at high risk participants than
participants who had risk factor values
within the normal range
and the other piece of data that i want
to show you as a cancer researcher
is the study from last year that
randomized 131 patients with breast
cancer
to either a fasting mimicking diet or
their regular diet for three days prior
to
and during chemotherapy and what they
found was that those who underwent
fmd were more often seen to have a
partial response or a radiologically
complete response
to the chemotherapy in addition the fmd
reduced chemotherapy induced
dna damage in the t cells and one of the
potential reasons to explain the
enhanced effects of combining
chemotherapy
with the fmd is what faulted terms
differential stress resistance
the idea that once you've entered a
starved state the cells
enter a highly protected non-engraved
modes but a cancer cell will disobey
this order and continue to grow
and so as you can see in this figure
here the hypothesis is that
whilst chemotherapy acts on both cancer
cells and normal cells
by inducing the non-grave protective
state of the cells
by combining chemotherapy with fmd
it selectively targets the cancerous
cells reducing the side effects
associated with chemotherapy
however this would need to be validated
in much larger clinical studies
in addition to trying to apply fmd to
much larger cohorts and to other
age-associated diseases
and information about upcoming clinical
trials can be found on folter's facebook
page
where you'll also find links to your
favorite youtuber
anyway i also think there's a lot of
work that could be done to further
explore the molecular mechanism
underpinning especially this
rejuvenation process
that happens in the refeeding process
post the five day fasting
for example be interesting just to see
how the epigenetic marks are changed
during this process and where those
changes are taking place
and in what tissues i say this only as
there seems to be some evidence in mice
that once they've
stopped during the fmd cycles they
continue to show
benefits in terms of the molecular risk
factors hinting at a potential
epigenetic memory
and this rate is another point as to how
often should this fmd be undertaken to
be effective
moreover it'd be interesting to see
actual biological age measurements be
taken
and it'd also be interesting to see if
this fmd is actually
impacting senescent cells whether it's
aiding with the clearance
or helping to activate the immune cells
that can clear the senescent cells in
the first place
but despite these open questions the fmd
really does seem quite promising
so much that i might have somehow
convinced you to try it however i'm
going to reinforce what folder says in a
review article that i covered
a month ago that although fmds appeared
to be safe
their use should be limited to three
times per year and healthy people with
normal levels of disease risk factors
until additional and long-term clinical
studies demonstrating the safety of more
frequent use are carried out
basically there's still some unknowns
about the fmd
and it's also important that you do
consult with your doctor before doing it
in particular because the fmd has been
designed in a manner such that you're
not at risk of nutritional deficiencies
but with that i hope this video has
given you a better insight into what the
fmd
actually is how it's working and why it
seems to be working
in addition to some data regarding the
fmd so with that
i want to say thank you to my patreon
supporters i hope you've learned
something in this video and as always
thanks for listening